what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to chief
keep
featuring lil reese reese i don't like
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel as you guys
know i am trying to hit 20 000
subscribers that's a big goal for the
channel
so do not forget to hit that subscribe
button and get
and ring the notification bell that way
you're going to be notified for my daily
videos
all right let's get this party started
[Music]
light on light jimmy baby
think i can get captions on this video
[Music]
um
okay oh i get it i get it so he's saying
that if you snitch
he does not like it so
um chief keef
king sosa what or sosa whatever his name
is
he does not like snitches
does not
[Music]
don't like
[Music]
okay so he gets his girl is
very attractive and he also likes to
smoke marijuana
[Music]
okay so they're saying we don't fight
our guns fight
it looks like there's gonna be a
shooting battle like the one person
shoots at the other
the other person shoots at the
[Music]
any of these guys have shirts on
can you guys not afford shirts i just
don't get it aren't you cold
and this guy's got a jean he's got a
jean jacket on
okay and no shirt that defeats the whole
purpose of the jacket
did he say a sneak disser okay that's
someone that disses you behind your back
[Music]
okay so he doesn't like knock off shoes
so like
when you go to certain areas you get
people that like knock off certain
brands of shoes
and he says i don't like that but
personally
if i can get the same shoes that look
exactly the same
i'm gonna buy it i'm not above it i like
a bargain you guys already know that
fake news that's that i don't like
stalking down light
i didn't gotta
[Music]
okay so when he says play on both sides
i'm pretty sure that's when there's like
an
argument right and you go to one person
right
and you might say oh my gosh that other
person like person a
right person a person b you go to person
a and say person b
trash i cannot believe person b did this
this and this women
girls we do this all the time then you
go to person b and you say person a
oh my god the worst that's called being
two-faced
and he's letting you know he doesn't
like it not his style
one time smart day all night
[Music]
don't like
[Music]
okay so he's saying if you're not with
us or with it
you can die that's he's he's thrown out
some threats
[Music]
floating off a flat i might take flight
free 100 if we hot
we didn't took flight take it
down we like the price thirsty
that we don't like otf dbo
flight what is that otf standpoint
[Music]
they're not even really doing dance
moves they're not even really doing
dance moves they're just jumping
[Music]
um in terms of song you guys already
know
this song dominated about a decade ago
like it was very popular you looked
pretty cool at parties dancing it to it
therefore i'm gonna give this song a 10
out of 10. let me know
in the comments okay what song i should
react to
next and do not forget to subscribe to
the channel i'm trying to get to 20 000
subscribers
as you know each and every one of you
helps i'm gonna talk to you guys
next time